[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
hallo liebe Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer
hier sind wir wieder Mirko und Toni und
wir machen heute mal was Neues ja wir
vertiefen uns heute in einen Fall der
noch nicht abgeschlossen ist der genauer
gesagt aktuell noch in einem Prozess
verhandelt wird unsere Ansprechpartnerin
für diese Geschichte ist mal wieder Lena
Zander bildreporterin und bei uns im
Ressort für investigativ Recherchen sie
findet das sehr viel Drama in diesem
Fall steckt der Fall hat alles was man
sich wünschen kann als Reporter Sex Mord
eine Stücke Leiche in obi-eimern im See
versenkt ich glaube mehr geht nicht also
in meiner ganzen Karriere bei Gericht
habe ich keinen Fall erlebt der
vergleichbar ist weil hier wirklich
alles zusammen kommt was spannend ist
und was auch einen in die menschlichen
Abgründe schauen lässt aus der Sicht von
Angehörigen und Freunden des Opfers
beginnt diese Geschichte wie so viele
dieser Art jemand wird vermisst in
diesem Fall der studierte Soziologe
Daniel matissek der 39-Jährige Hesse
verschwindet um den 17 November 2016 die
Bild-Zeitung berichtet damals
der mysteriöse vermissten Fall mattisek
er verschwindet spurlos aus seiner
Wohnung in Hanau
das sieht aus als wenn er gerade mal um
die Ecke gegangen wäre sagt sein Vater
Helmut das Handy des Soziologen ist
seither ausgeschaltet trotz
umfangreicher suche Steckbriefen
Aufrufen in den Medien und einer
vermisstenseite auf Facebook gibt es
nicht den Hauch einer Spur von ihm im
Jahr darauf gibt es kurz Verwirrung 2017
heißt es in der Presse wo ist Daniel
matissek
das fragt nach wie vor die
Kriminalpolizei in Hanau und bittet die
Bevölkerung insbesondere im Raum
Heidelberg und mit Hilfe bei der Suche
nach dem vermissten der 39-Jährige hat
am
17.11.2016 ohne erkennbaren Grund seine
Wohnung in Hanau verlassen und ist
bisher nicht wieder zurückgekehrt
ein Zeuge will den Vermissten nun am 29
August 2017 in Heidelberg gesehen haben
aber das ist ein Irrtum
die Zeit zieht ins Land und die
Ungewissheit bleibt aber die Polizei
behält den Fall im Blick ermittelt im
Umfeld von Daniel befragt also Familie
und Freunde oder um es im Krimi Deutsch
zu sagen der Ermittlungsdruck steigt das
zeigt schließlich Wirkung im Mai 2020
meldet sich ein gewisser Olaf C bei der
Polizei er ist Mathelehrer und ein enger
Freund von Daniel mattisek er meldet
einen Mord und belastet gegenüber den
Beamten einen Freund namens Robert s der
Software Spezialist gehörte zum gleichen
engen Freundeskreis moment mal also
warum kommt da nach rund vier Jahren
einer ums Eck mit einer Mordgeschichte
das hat sich auch Reporterin Lena Zander
gefragt das ist auch eine sehr dubiose
Geschichte es gibt dazu eine Version und
die lautet so und zwar Olaf C fühlte
sich bedroht von Robert es Robert es hat
wohl gesagt er hätte manipulierte
Beweise und er könnte damit Olaf C so
die Schuld in die Schuhe an diesem Ort
stecken und daraufhin ist Olaf zählt zu
Polizei und hat gesagt hilfe hilfe bitte
ähm ich gestehe hier dass ein Mord
passiert ist aber wer letztendlich
geschossen hat wäre letztendlich der
Mörder ist das ist natürlich auch die
Frage die das Gericht jetzt klärt
was wir euch jetzt hier vortragen das
ist ein Ablauf der sich aus den
Schilderungen der Verdächtigen den
Ergebnissen der Ermittlungen und aus der
Anklageschrift ergibt es gibt noch kein
Urteil und bis zum Ende des Prozesses
gilt die Unschuldsvermutung also hier
kommt die Geschichte die sich zugetragen
haben könnte
Olaf und Daniel sind beste Freunde sie
gehen zusammen in der hessischen Provinz
zur Schule machen Abi dann ziehen sie
weiter in die große Stadt studieren
gemeinsam in Frankfurt am Main hier
lernen Sie den Dritten im Bunde kennen
Robert aus Bayern die drei sind
unzertrennlich kennen die Schwächen der
anderen zum Beispiel das Lehrer Olaf
gern ins Bordell geht und dort viel Geld
lässt
Olaf der Puffgänger scherzhaft nennen
sie ihn deshalb pufflaff
für Prostitution haben im übrigen
offenbar alle drei eine Schwäche im Jahr
2016 geraten zwei der Kumpels in
Schräglage
sowohl Programmierer Robert als auch
Lehrer Olaf plagen akute Geldsorgen der
eine verliert seinen gut bezahlten
softwarejob und der andere der lässt zu
viel Geld bei Prostituierten nur daniel
hat in dieser Hinsicht keinen Kummer der
Geist ist Wissenschaftler kommt aus
einer wohlhabenden Familie sein Vater
ist Ingenieur und betreibt in der Region
eine wirklich gut gehende Firma der Sohn
soll 100.000 € auf dem Konto haben nach
allem was man heute weiß schmieden die
zwei Pleitegeier einen üblen Plan am
Abend ist 17 November 2016 holen Olaf
und Robert ihren Freund Daniel von
dessen Wohnung in Hanau mit dem Auto ab
der Vorwand sie wollen sich eine
Immobilie ansehen genauer gesagt geht es
um einen alten Hof in dem man zu dritt
einen Swingerclub betreiben könnte
vielleicht geht die Fahrt sogar noch
fröhlich los man scherzt über die
vorgeblichen Sexclub Pläne Mal hat sich
die Zukunft aus aber irgendwann auf dem
Rückweg kippt die Situation
irgendwann erzählen Olaf und Robert
ihrem Freund Daniel dass sie dessen
Entführung vortäuschen wollen um die
reichen Eltern zu erpressen er hat sie
doch wohl nicht mehr alle sagt Daniel
vielleicht oder das ist nicht euer Ernst
was auch immer genau passiert im Auto
fällt ein Schuss aus einer Waffe mit
einem Schalldämpfer dann noch einer
Daniel auf dem Beifahrersitz wird in
Kopf und Oberkörper getroffen und stirbt
was also ist da genau passiert
Daniels Mörder belasten sich später
gegenseitig laut Robert war Olaf die
treibende Kraft der wiederum schildert
die todeszene vor Gericht so
auf der Heimfahrt saß ich auf dem
Fahrersitz und höre ein Klacken kurz
danach ein schweres Schnaufen und als
ich auf den Beifahrersitz schaue ist
Daniel in sich zusammengesackt auf der
Rückbank sitzt Robert mit einer großen
Pistole samt Schalldämpfer
er setzt die Waffe noch mal an dieses
Mal am Kopf
er drückt wieder ab
Olaf will also von den tödlichen
Schüssen vollkommen überrascht worden
sein und das mal einzuschieben die
todeszene im Auto die gesamte Situation
die ist bis heute rätselhaft
wieso entführten die Männer ihren besten
Kumpel und knallen ihn dann ab
Lena Zander das ist genau die Frage die
sich so viele Menschen stellen die Frage
die sich auch das Gericht stellt ich
meine es ist ja schon irgendwie ein
bisschen dämlich jemanden zu entführen
ins Auto zu setzen und sagen ach
übrigens wir entführen dich jetzt man
sieht eine Pistole es kommt so lange
leihen dann löst sich ein Schluss so die
Kanten sich das waren Freunde gerade
Olaf sie und Daniel matissek die waren
jahrelang eng miteinander befreundet ich
meine wenn ich dich jetzt entführen
würde Stefan du würdest mich auch wieder
erkennen es war einfach nicht durchdacht
in diesem Fall sind so viele Sachen
offen auch so viele Sachen die auch der
Angeklagte der aussagt der Olaf sie
nicht wirklich beantworten kann
eine Frage die geklärt werden muss
definitiv aber die bisher offen bleibt
aber wir haben ja noch ein bisschen Zeit
der Prozess läuft ja auch schon seit
zwei Jahren und bisher ist nicht
absehbar wann das ganze ändert fest
steht dass Entführer Duo ist nicht weit
gekommen und ihr Opfer ist tot
Olaf und Robert ändern ihren Plan sie
wollen kein Lösegeld mehr sondern nur
noch alle Spuren verwischen sie fahren
mit der Leiche zum Hofgrundstück von
Robert und zersägen sie die Organe
vergraben sie im Wald mit dem Rest
Verfahren sie ziemlich umständlich die
Mörder für den zerkleinerte Leichenteile
in orangefarbene Eimer aus dem Baumarkt
und gießen dann Beton Estrich darauf als
der Beton getrocknet ist werden die
einmal angeblich mit dem Auto von Hessen
zum Starnberger See nach Bayern gebracht
und dort versenkt
aber wer saß bei der Entsorgung der
Leichenteile mit dem Auto und was wusste
die Mutter von Robert es
Antworten auf diese Fragen gibt es im
Prozess hofft zumindest
polizeireporterin Lena Zander Robert S
hat eine Mutter und die hat erstmal von
ihrem
Zeugnisverweigerungsrecht Gebrauch
gemacht weil als Mutter als direkte
Angehörige muss man ja nicht aussagen
wenn man jemanden aus der Familie
jemanden da stehenden belastet so jetzt
hat sie gesagt ich möchte doch Aussagen
und man erhofft sich von dieser Aussage
dass da ein bisschen was darum kommt
dass man vielleicht auch die
Leichenteile von Daniel Matthies Weg
finden kann weil es gibt wohl
Anhaltspunkte dafür dass Ursula es mit
ihrem Sohn Robert es im Auto gesessen
hat während diese ist da jetzt mal rund
450 km von Hanau nach Bayern an den
Starnberger See zurückgelegt worden und
sie kann sich wohl noch ganz gut an den
beißenden Geruch erinnern der aus den
Obi einmal in ihre Nase stieg den
Aussagen folgend muss die Polizei also
davon ausgehen dass die Eimer mit den
Leichen Teilen im Starnberger See liegen
dazu noch mal Lena ganz genau aber
trotzdem die Ermittler haben am
Starnberger See alles versucht die haben
die Leiche gesucht die haben alles auf
dem Kopf gestellt was sie auf dem Kopf
stellen konnten haben aber diese
obi-eimer in denen ja die zerstückelte
Leiche einbetoniert wurde nicht gefunden
muss dazu sagen der Starnberger See ist
wahnsinnig groß und selbst die gleichen
Teile des Teenies hat man bis heute
nicht gefunden der Tod des Kini des
bayerischen Königs Ludwig im Jahr 1886
erst bis heute ungeklärt
im Mordfall Daniel matyssek gibt es
dagegen noch Hoffnung auf Klarheit
im Prozess gibt es 2022 plötzlich
Hinweise darauf dass die Leiche woanders
sein könnte
Ermittler äußern die Vermutung dass die
Körperteile von Daniel mattisek
vielleicht im sachsensee in Hessen
versenkt wurden also viel viel mehr am
Tatort als gedacht der sachsensee an
einem kalten grauen februar-tag am Ufer
schlottert bild-reporterin Lena Zander
vor sich hin und beobachtet die
mühselige Arbeit der Taucher es war auch
die erste Leichensuche in einem See die
ich begleitet habe und ich muss sagen es
war sehr viel stehen sehr viel warten
sehr viel gucken nicht nur für mich
sondern auch für die Beteiligten es war
bitterkalt es war im Februar letzten
Jahres und die Suche musste dann auch
verschoben werden auf den nächsten Tag
weil die Taucher natürlich auch eine
gewisse Zeit im Einsatz sein können das
ist wirklich wahnsinnig mühsam und man
stellt sich das vielleicht sehr
aufregend vor das ist es aber nicht weil
wirklich kleinen teilig geschaut wird
und dann schlägt der Roboter aus der
zuerst in dem sie drin ist und komplett
geguckt okay gut hier an diesem Punkten
wo der Roboter ausgeschlagen hat das
schicken wir jetzt noch mal ein Taucher
runter und gucken ob da was ist das ist
so ein bisschen wie so ein Puzzle was
ich dann zusammensetzt ja und am Ende
haben sie leider nichts gefunden was
gerade für Daniel matti6 Vater und auch
für seine Mutter wahnsinnig schlimm ist
weil die ihren Sohn immer noch nicht
beerdigen konnten ne vier Jahre nach dem
Mord war zwar klar wer die Täter sind
aber noch immer gibt es keine Spur von
Daniel matissek
ab april 2021 stehen die beiden
Angeklagten vor Gericht der Fall wird zu
einem Mord ohne Leiche
eine Qual für die Eltern die sich im
Sommer 2022 an verschiedene Zeitungen
Wenden darin heißt es sechs Jahre nach
dem mutmaßlichen Mord an Daniel
mattisäcke wenden sich seine Eltern mit
einem Aufruf an die Öffentlichkeit für
Hinweise zur Auffindung der körperlichen
Überreste setzen Sie eine Geld zum aus
ihr Wunsch ist eine letzte Ruhestätte
für ihren Sohn zu finden um selbst
trauern und Abschied nehmen zu können
Daniels Vater sagt
ich setze eine Belohnung von 50.000 Euro
für denjenigen aus der uns den
entscheidenden Hinweis zur Auffindung
der Leiche meines Sohnes liefert bis
heute wurde keine Belohnung gezahlt
einfach weil es keine sachdienlichen
Hinweise gab
Lena Zander hat noch mehrfach mit dem
Vater gesprochen er sagt mir geht es
fürchterlich meiner Frau noch
schrecklicher sie kann kaum noch laufen
ich selbst war schon in der Kardiologie
muss bald zum Lungenarzt wir sind
dadurch krank geworden wir hoffen immer
noch dass wir durch den Prozess endlich
erfahren was mit unserem Sohn passiert
ist wie schon ganz am Anfang gesagt
dieser Prozess läuft und wenn es etwas
neues entscheidendes dabei gibt dann
sagen wir euch hier natürlich sofort
Bescheid und weil wir hier schon eben
eine Parallele zum Tod von König Ludwig
dem zweiten im Starnberger See gezogen
haben ist dies unser nächster Fall wir
freuen uns wenn ihr uns auch beim
nächsten Fall begleitet und wenn euch
gefällt was wir hier machen dann denkt
dran die Glocke zu aktivieren und uns
auch eine Bewertung da zu lassen Danke
Schön also bis zum nächsten mal eure
Toni und euer Marco